oh so well now it's the part of the show
where you need to call in and I have
done that many a time gone in way too
hard and upbeat on a sad bit about
people dying hello I'm John Whitehall
and I'm here to give you some advice
John from Glasgow don't wait in the
accident what's it like to have
appointment Freddie Flintoff he's
teetotal now when he drunk it was fun
but hard work he also insisted on a pint
glass when he couldn't get that he would
improvise this is a nightclub we went to
once way they wouldn't give him a beer
and a pint glass so he got a bottle of
beer and put it into his shoe I shot a
sex tape and it's not getting any views
any tips for my next attempt this please
real maybe pretend it was with a
celebrity so he was like a big a-list
star like food david hustle david
hasselhoff why is that the name that i
go to there must be more famous people
that i mean think of off the top of my
head other than a man it was like famous
thirty years ago I work on a panel show
like you the host always seems to take
all the attention after recently
breaking America how would you go about
disposing of him if we claimed that he
said something horrific ly racist in the
dressing room it's a good idea I need to
remember that my friend recently broke
up with his partner and I predicted it a
while back now everyone thinks I'm
somehow involved in a homewrecker how do
I shake this image are in penny can I
think your arm home-wrecking bossy and
I'm afraid that's Kim Fowley around so
Amanda I'm Jack Whitehall and in my own
words this is being led by war life
advice I hope that I've helped some of
your problems
[Music]